welcome to this video playing
international master dim yon from
Germany I won't reveal his identity it's
another teammate of mine ok let's see
let's see let's do something funny it's
not as bad as it looks ok he's trying to
do something oddly in the center ok
knight c6 oh is this not a good idea I
don't know
the funny thing is that tea for Hanks
yeah because my night is on age six and
this is really a difference okay so 95
lots of pressure happening on c6 so I
should probably cancel right he can of
course now take something on on c6 but
it will give me lots of open files and
there is still this counter play against
any form yep keep it simple approach
yeah interesting but I have this I
really have counter player and now
that's interesting Bishop g7 I mean this
is this diagonal is is long and it is
weakened I have five at least you have
or Bishop to e6 is also not bad trying
to win this directly I'm not sure about
it this is definitely okay for me the
question is if he goes III do I now play
rook v6 and tending Bishop a six or do I
play a five well if I've is definitely
good for black but I come on let's do
this let's not overthink things here
I will just win the depot or I mean I
don't think he can capture this looks
really problematic oet did capture okay
hm this really looks hard to believe
Bishop to a six Quincy five maybe
should be six or a six Bishop a six and
really should be good right Quincy five
probably Quincy five but then I think I
still have I just have no I don't have
that I thought queen d 6 but she can
take it oh yeah thought queen bee three
would be killing isn't it does this
shook this should win right Bishop takes
c3 and there's also Queenie to make it
to mate coming now this is winning and
there is no defense now I think Quincy
five but probably not don't think you
can hold this as well but I didn't see
how exactly i'm winning then many
interesting looking moves like even rock
be five of the move
wait resign ya know there's really no no
move but why this winning a white is
losing anyway right now after a five
Jeff is difficult I thought him 92 m
this is already lost the other dark
squares are really really too much of a
problem but I'd like to see the precise
window after that Bishop 2d6 is the
strongest move yeah I doubt that I would
have played that move which would be six
really I was thinking I was thinking
this first like this but yes has this
movement and this is really nothing
great I was also thinking that this
might be an idea but he can take it and
castle so I'm not sure if I would have
found this is there something I mean to
show what the idea is if I go here and
the comp wants to switch over to this
and now this is this is really over now
and white gets gets routed here route it
somewhat yeah route it it really really
is bad okay I guess this was interesting
thanks for watching